when you get good at what you do and you
provide a great service
you start demand listen if every day is
another reaction day
you are in a fixed mindset life isn't
about
having no fears it's about conquering
the fears wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the things
that 95 percent of people are not doing
and you need to enjoy
okay let's take it off with rule number
one seize the opportunity with kevin
hart
how do you go from toby you're selling
shoes at one stage of your life and you
get your breakthrough how do you go from
that to
you know one of the highest paid
entertainers in the world management
makes people laugh all over the earth
opportunity you know um when you
when you get dealt certain hands you
know sometimes you have no idea what the
turn is going to be
and for me it was always the thought
it was a thought of doing comedy but i
just never knew how
i never knew what to do with the
approach to take how to get there
and one day the suggestion came up from
co-workers
of kevin is an amateur knight right
around the corner the comedy club called
the laugh house in philadelphia you
should go do it
and i was like i would love to do it i
never knew that these things existed
and when i got the opportunity to do
that i fell in love with the moment
that i didn't know how to go get i fell
in love with the spotlight with the
stage that i didn't know existed
for me i didn't know it was available
for me at that time and
once i found out how to get it there was
there was nothing else that mattered
except that it was about that and that
only
rule number two have a growth mindset
with brendan burchard
if brendan showed up in your house today
and we we
we opened up another tab and we opened
up your calendar
and i stepped through your calendar for
the next six months
is it terribly obvious to me
what you are working on what skills
you're trying to develop
what projects you're trying to complete
to stretch yourself to grow yourself
or is every day another reaction day
because listen if every day is another
reaction day
you are in a fixed mindset
write it down if every day is another
reaction day
you're in a fixed mindset you stop
believing
in big projects that would require you
to schedule stuff out
you stopped thinking what skills must i
master to grow
because you're just trying to handle all
the problems remember you're stuck in
one signal of problems
so a development plan what does that
mean
what's the next five books you're going
to read what are they
here's the difference if you know you
have books and a development plan or you
just have books
okay if you have a development plan you
know the next
five books you're going to read why
because you began with an outcome
not just chasing down a bestseller or an
interest
or what showed up in your inbox you said
i'm trying to develop the skill of
public speaking so your next five books
are on public speaking
i'm trying to grow my business your next
five books on scaling the business
i'm trying to improve my marriage next
five books on your marriage
now obviously i'm using books as as a
metaphor but maybe that
books is online courses maybe that
that books is online live cast like this
maybe that
books is podcasts i don't know why this
became a podcast i don't think this is a
podcast sign
okay you've got to figure out okay what
is my development plan
what are the conferences the courses the
events
the trainings virtual online in person
who are my mentors what are the
resources i'm going to stack up
and when am i going to consume them
that's what's important
please listen please listen let me break
down the development plan for you
ready number one outcome
what am i trying to grow into what am i
trying to improve
what am i trying to make happen see a
growth mindset
needs you to cast out an outcome
growth mindset doesn't just say i'm good
i can learn no there's an
objective i'm gonna get better at that
test
i'm gonna improve that marriage i'm
gonna lose that ten pounds
i'm gonna be more active there's
something there there's an outcome
then we work backwards okay what must i
learn to grow into that outcome
what must i learn about myself what
skills must i develop
what can i learn from other people you
know every outcome i've ever after in my
life
i read biographies of people who already
achieved that outcome
i buy books that are specifically built
for that outcome
i follow listen or consume content or
courses
or trainings like this from people who
already achieved that outcome
and i listen to how they think i listen
to what they do and i
most importantly on top of the outcome
right number i said development plan
number one outcome
number two what must i learn what must i
learn okay
what must i learn number three
how will i learn it
how will i learn it books podcasts
following this person going these
conferences
engaging virtually like this but number
four
and here it is this is why i brought up
the calendar
notice brendan the little productivity
kid getting excited about this calendar
thing come on people i know it's weird
but listen
it's got to show up in your calendar you
don't have a development plan
even if you have a full shelf of books
let me say it out loud for a halloween
you don't have a development plan just
because i have a full shelf of books
when will you read what when will you
take what
when will you try what a development
plan
is fundamentally fixed
in its success based on scheduling all
right my friend evan carmichael's book
listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them
but in either case humans are built to
serve so if you're not happy right now
it's because you're not serving enough
you got to pick up this book because
it's so inspiring to remind you that
we're all here to contribute
to make a difference to make an impact
and this is your field guide
for that rule number three have the
drive with michael phelps
the biggest thing was was after going to
my first olympics in 2000 when i was 15
um i i i decided to not take a break
afterwards and kind of get right back
into it because it's the same thing that
he was talking about
i was upset with my performance you know
i got fifth and
at 15 yeah it's great but i mean let's
be honest i don't want to come back with
a
participation like ribbon like i want to
come back with
real hardware like i don't want this
[ __ ] ribbon
so i like i was pissed about it so like
you know like
like i i that's that's just what i
wanted so i was like all right cool so
we got back in the water the next day
everyone else took like a month or two
off
and i remember the very first workout we
did as the meat's going on
bob has wr written on the top of the
workout and i'm like
what what is this like i know what it
means but like why are you writing it
here
and he's like because we're gonna break
a world record in six months
i was like all right decide yeah let's
do it
cool i'm in six months later first world
record
six months after that broke another one
won my first world championship
and he just started proving to me that
he could get me to these certain places
and we just started pressing the
envelope even more we're like all right
what do we want to do next how big can
we really take this and
and um you know i remember sitting with
my agent when i was 15 16 years old and
i just said i want to do something
nobody else has ever done in the sport i
want to do something different
i don't want to be the second mark spitz
i want to be the first michael phelps
i want to do something nobody else has
ever done that's awesome
and and that's honestly really just what
drove me
rule number four always keep learning
with simon sinek
leaders great leaders are students of
leadership no matter how achieved they
may be they're still learning
and it's a lifestyle it's the lifestyle
of what i need to do to look after
people which includes things like
listening uh learning how to give and
receive feedback
learning how to have effective
confrontations how to discipline when
necessary
in a way that's constructive
roam the halls get to know people
learning what it means to
to ask somebody questions how do you ask
questions
you know like some people are naturally
good at being curious
about other human beings and some people
are uncomfortable because they're
introverts or whatever
socially awkward but we can learn you
know how do you learn to remember
people's names
well i'm bad at names no you've just
decided you're bad at names
we can learn to be good at names so that
when we walk down the hall and say hey
tom
oh my god he remembers my name it's a
nice feeling
it's a lifestyle it's a lifestyle there
are many many things we have to do and
constantly work on
to be a great leader to create that
environment rule number five
master your craft with eric thomas when
you get good at what you do and you
provide a great service
you start demanding i remember when
people would fly me on two flights to
get me somewhere
i'm like going to atlanta they didn't
flew me from huntsville alabama to
dallas
i'm saying dallas and i could have drove
quicker to get
here they didn't put me over everybody
that's guess why
because i was an average speaker when i
became number one i didn't have to
negotiate i don't negotiate anymore
some of y'all are negotiating not
because of the company
you negotiate because you're not the
best at what you do and i need y'all to
go back and be the best at what you do
and then i need y'all to come together
as the best and then take this thing to
the next level
are you hearing what i'm saying somebody
like i am the best okay you make
everybody else the best
so that's the next thing after you
become the best
you open up the doors and train other
people to be the best at what they do
does that make sense
no i want to make sure you hear what i'm
saying i single-handedly with carl
phillips got on youtube the two of us
and we changing the world it don't take
10 people
i got on youtube every monday and said
thank god it's monday
and i didn't get a dime for it i didn't
get any sponsors for it
the president when obama went obama was
in office and i love obama he never
called me and was like yo e
i appreciate the free videos bro i see
what you're doing in the schools
and guess what it didn't bother me
because i wasn't doing it for the
president
so trumping off is not he ain't called
i'm not tripping
you feel me no i'm just being real some
of you thinking take
10 of y'all and you talking about your
director or the person that
it's you you you're the one that's gonna
make the difference i was a i i didn't
have my masters when i started doing
tgim
i had no phd i didn't write no book i
just got on with my positive energy
in a recession i did it during the
recession
and the numbers blew up and i became
number one habit number six
find execution skills with kevin o'leary
you want to be successful work with
people that can achieve
goals also in other words find
executional skills
men or women that you can work with that
when you set a goal you say okay we're
going to get to a million in sales
in six months that they can actually do
that
because if you surround yourself with
people even if you don't like them
that can actually execute be given goals
and execute that's a
big deal my whole life i've learned that
lesson i've always tried to surround
myself with people
that have executional skills that are
better at me at some things
particularly like i don't like making
widgets i hate
logistics and manufacturing it sucks i
don't like it
but i find people that know how to do it
and are willing
to set goals and achieve them and i
compensate them very very well for that
because i want them to stay i'm a
marketer i'm a salesman
i set goals i achieve them i try and do
it consistently
the greatest thing about sales about
identifying talent and sales
to achieve success is consistency
don't set goals that they can't achieve
but set goals that they agree to
and let them achieve them consistently
and rule number seven the last one
before every special bonus
clip is give yourself over with tom
bilyeu
if you want to get great if you really
want to make a skill set your own if you
want to be able to do something and at
the end of the day
if you want to transform the world if
you want to make grand changes if you
want to do
all of that all the empty words that
people spout
all the time let me tell you
the only thing that's going to separate
you from all the other blowhards who are
just talking words
and will never do anything
is to give yourself over completely to
let that obsession
let that thing that you love completely
consume you
and in that your only chance to
really become great lies
as friends kafka said don't bend don't
water down don't try to make it logical
rather
follow your most intense obsessions
mercilessly can you do that
can you become mercilessly obsessed
can you let something occupy you to
where all
logic and reason is gone out the window
and the only thing that matters
is whether or not you accomplish will
you hold yourself accountable to metrics
will you look at the world and see am i
actually
making change are you prepared to hold
yourself to that standard because if you
are there is nothing you can't do if
you're willing to take that
responsibility on
to transform yourself as a human being
if you
give your self over
to getting great
if you give yourself over to that
obsession if you feed it
like you would feed a beast if you feed
it like you would feed a fire that can
wipe out an entire mountainside
then you've got a chance but it's got to
burn within you like that you've got to
feed it like that you've got to feed its
skills
you've got to get better every day
you've got to constantly
wake up and understand exactly what it
is you're building towards that and
build towards it with a relentlessness
that other people think is mania that
other people can see
only madness in what you do
and if you can push yourself to that
level
then the world will bend to your will
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific
plan of action for when and how you're
going to do it
your number jumps from 35 to 91 percent
chance of following through
and when you commit to somebody else
like posting down here in the comments
below
that number jumps to 95 percent i want
to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you
and in all honesty last year when i
spoke at growth
i i had the biggest panic attack of my
life backstage
it's ten minutes before going live
there's this big wind up and lead up and
like
just bring me out just bring me out i
can't wait to go and and my heart's
going like crazy
and uh i just forgot how i was gonna
start my presentation
right i just i just blank have you guys
had that happen were you like
you're about to get on a call or
presentation he just you had it all down
you practiced
a thousand times but then you just go
blank great that was me
just before about to come up and speak
to you know a couple thousand people
it was the first time i was gonna i met
brendan
so you know he invited me out we
connected through ethan as the first
time i met him he was doing an interview
backstage
and he said hey i'm going to end my
interview because i want to make sure
that i'm watching your presentation
like oh my gosh come on really can't you
just like
have a coffee or something backstage but
it's but it's great and he's going to
give me feedback like oh my god okay i'm
i'm ready for the feedback
and so i get on stage and do my thing
but just before that what got me over it
was i took a little peek behind the
curtain
and i saw a bunch of you guys and i
reminded myself that i'm not here for me
i'm here for you right don't be so
selfish
right yeah you can cut that up
it's not about me it's about the message
and so the reason why and even this even
this lead up here i'm sitting backstage
ethan's like
calming me down because my heart's going
crazy brandon is talking about the
genius ideas that i told him backstage
like oh my god brandon like the setup
i better deliver and i tell you this
because
i've seen a lot of people from the
arizona event i got stopped a lot over
the past couple days
and they said evan i loved your your
speech it was amazing like oh thank you
did you start your channel
where is it it's like oh no i haven't
done it yet
like what that was how many months ago
you loved my speech for what happened
and at the end of the day it's just fear
you can come up with a really logical
reason why
you haven't posted yet but really you're
afraid that it's not perfect you're
afraid that no one's gonna watch it
you're afraid that people are gonna
watch it
you know you're afraid you don't know
the technology you don't have the gear
you know the team you're just afraid
afraid afraid afraid and we cover it
with the reason why we can't do it right
or really it's just fear
and so i wanted to share my fear with
you because you might look at
dean and brendan and all these mentors
that you have and they come on stage and
they just look amazing
he's like well i can never be like that
but at least for my story
i'm always scared right like i'm always
playing anxious and nervous i think if
you don't have anything that makes you
anxious and nervous in your life then
you hate your life
right because then you're just staying
inside your comfort zone you know
exactly what to do you're photocopying
your life over and over and over again
and so
life isn't about having no fears it's
about conquering the fears what what
dean said yesterday about having the
courage to jump out of the helicopter
right to be like
on the edge here the helicopter of the
plane and say i'm gonna jump to have the
courage to do that
that's what you guys need to do and why
i share it is because
the biggest reason why you guys aren't
taking the action on the most logical
opportunity the biggest opportunity in
front of your face right now is just
because of fear
[Music]
if you want to know the habits of
successful people check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there get that dream
and i'm just been telling you drive it
and drive it and drive it and drive it
what i've been talking about is
consistency and for some of you for real
for real you'll never have it
you'll never be it you'll never do it
because you don't have any consistency